lui comparaissait devant le tribunal de
tours pour exhibition sexuelle un homme
aperçu dénudées et se masturbant danse
des parcs de la métropole deux tours
plus de 50 fait à son actif receipts
d'audience avec lucas chopin c'est
penaud que le prévenu de 53 ans s'est
présenté à la barre du tribunal de tours
et pour cause on reproche à ce père de
famille plus de 50 faits d'exhibition
sexuelle commis entre 2017 et 2020
l'homme a sévit principalement face à
des jeunes femmes dans les quartiers
étudiants de mon joyeux et grandmont au
sud de tours sans casier judiciaire il
ne parvient pas à expliquer ses gestes
qui relève des pulsions aujourd'hui il
se dit prête à être soignés comme le
confirme son avocate maître isabelle
géré des monsieur a exprimé
effectivement ses regrets
et ça monte aussi un vis-à-vis de la
situation et d'entendre les victimes qui
étaient présentes je pense que c'était
bien pour lui aussi pour conscientiser
tout ça et pouvoir travailler derrière
sur sur une réadaptation et les soins
quoi les réquisitions du procureur ont
globalement été suivi l'exhibitionniste
a été reconnu coupable et condamné à un
an de prison avec sursis
il écope également d'une obligation de
soins strictes et d'une interdiction
formelle d'approcher les lieux où il a
commis les faits heureux dans son
malheur celui personnes se sont portées
partie civile il devra leur verser en
tout près de 8000 euros de dommages et
intérêts